bueno el motivo que todavía no está
escrutado el 100% es por dos temas el
primero
existen en recintos electorales de
difícil acceso deporte cuyos documentos
se pueden sacar a las delegaciones
provinciales a través de vía fluvial o
aérea
entonces dependemos de que incluso del
tiempo en que los helicópteros puedan
entrar a estos recintos y sacar la
documentación este momento ya está el
1,4 por ciento pendiente de este tipo de
recintos especialmente en la amazonía
que se tiene que sacar los documentos
para procesarlos
en el otro tema que está el 13 20 por
ciento de trabajada que por trabajar es
en las actas que han tenido alguna
inconsistencia puede ser numérica o por
falta de firmas de los miembros de la
junta receptora del voto se está
trabajando en estos dos temas
esperemos que máximas del día de mañana
ella se encuentren en los documentos de
difícil acceso de los recintos que
vienen desde la parte interna de la
amazonía y también el asa el tema de las
de las actas que estaban pendientes